hey guys Brian right here hey what's up
Luke bass song is the co-writer of the
takin movies so we thought we'd talk
about this movie called the professional
his first big film he wrote and directed
it I saw this film when I was young
loved it and I introduced it to Veronica
recently because I knew she would love
it you loved it right yeah so if you
haven't seen it go check it out there's
gonna be spoilers in this one so go
check it out be worth their time we're
gonna be talking about Leon the
professional that's the director's cut
which I prefer there's so many great
things about this movie I mean just from
beginning to end I think it's like
pretty much perfect the introduction is
like uh it's like a prologue for the
story with a set up the first ten
minutes really doesn't have anything to
do with the rest of the film
it's just establishing like this guy's
what he's the professional hat basically
it pulls the audience in immediately
especially with the the close-ups you
can't really they don't really reveal
much so you just want to know right from
the start you want to know more you want
to see more yeah it's it's visually
appealing from the from the very
beginning when he's like taking out the
bad guys that for the first time you see
him do it cuz that's what film
progresses when you see him killed you
actually see him kill people in the
beginning
kinda like a ninja you know just a sad
he's like a lethal assassin and then
when he has the guy up with a knife
against the guy's throat who he has to
send a message to he's not even like
sweating you know he's really like all
black a jacket and a beanie in
sunglasses yeah he got there incredibly
fast and he's not breaking a sweat the
details of him his boss says make sure
he understands and let him go rather
than a whole hitman speech and like
punching the guy he just goes like you
know he doesn't know what to do and it's
kind of adorable in a weird way you just
do you understand because he has no clue
what to do except to kill one stuff well
I didn't think I was adorable I didn't
think he was adorable until I saw his
adore
well that introduction to his adorable
side is a great scene that's when he's
watching
I think it's singing in the rain bit and
he's in the theater and he just has that
little voice my heart completely forget
he's a hit man you like looks behind him
to see if anybody else is enjoying -
he's incredibly lonely pulls you in
emotionally for me at least this film is
very character-driven those are my
favorite kind of action films are
character-driven action pieces you don't
get too many of those nowadays
and when I say character-driven it's
really character driven right like the
first 10 to 15 minutes after the
prologue is just looking at this dude's
life style you know gene Reno's the
actor's name plays Leon and he's amazing
he's great so what happened it is crazy
I know it saddens me that he hasn't
worked more as an actor because in this
he's just absolutely wonderful and I
asked you after we watched it why what's
up with that and you said that maybe it
was about his his look because he
doesn't have that like a Hollywood look
like that's why I like to think that the
lucra song casted him he doesn't have
the typical Hollywood look the typical
Hollywood presence that's kind of a bold
choice to do that and it worked
perfectly like he's as French actor
who's fantastic he's absolutely
fantastic and you know like Natalie
Portman's in it that first shot of her
in the hallway was just so awesome she's
smoking a cigarette she looks like a
little bad ass kid her outfit and then
she sees Leon walking up the steps you
automatically know that there's some
kind of chemistry that she feels for him
through her eyes just she watches him
like a cat it's an instant connection I
mean they're distant at first and Leon
doesn't has no idea how to bond but when
that film progresses into them bonding
like they introduced right after that
they introduce her family because she
lives in a domestically violent home her
dad's really abusive involved with
gangsters I love the idea of the villain
because the villains play by Gary Oldman
even though he has a lot more
recognition now in a lot more respect
now more than
and he finally got an academy and we're
nomination a couple years back I still
think he's underrated in a lot of ways
he has this ability you know you watch
Commissioner Gordon and Batman he's
believable the second you see him and
then you watch him as a villain in this
he's believable the second you stand
like he just embodies the role he's
unique he's listening to music on his
like mp3 player Walkman he does that
thing what is he doing no you like takes
them he'll like yeah what's he what's he
taking yeah and we don't have to know
that's what's neat about admit knowing
making a mysterious kind of makes you
boy worry even more about it he's creepy
like he starts sniffing Natalie
Portman's tenet purse like what's he
doing but well it's great about his
performances even if we don't understand
exactly what he's doing Gary Oldman
understands what he's doing with that
comes aren't us accepting and believing
it yeah exactly he's so into it that
scene where the family's being massacred
heartbreaking that's like the most
violent moments of the film I mean the
the daughter the not not only not
Matilda but her stepsister is just
crying dad dad the entire time and
they're [ __ ] frumpy dad it's just
sitting in the corner like a coward
that's scene is so intense I like how
the movie didn't hold back on that too
because it's a perfect way to establish
that these guys are the real deal when
it comes to being villains yeah they
don't care if it's kids they're gonna
[ __ ] murder them you know the thing
is when I was a little confused about
was how messy it was I mean I know Gary
Oldman's character is like a total nut
but it was not well done you know oh you
mean the actual crime yeah well he can
get away with it because he's like that
one of the people at the DEA which i
think is a great thing to throw in the
film wondering how the hell did he
become like head of the DEA yeah I don't
know his exact position but he's high in
the law enforcement and stuff my
favorite moment is actually after the
massacre because not my favorite moment
in the movie my favorite moment Natalie
Portman's is because after the massacre
Natalie Portman's she's picking up milk
for Leone there's so much emotion
without
hircine [ __ ] she's this 12 year old girl
no acting lessons from my understanding
but she has such a natural intuition and
feeling that she walks past the family
her her master family can we say right
before that when she's when she's
getting the milk and stuff
she's just so blissful and excited that
she's doing a favor for early on and
then from from that she comes in - yeah
theme she walks past the family
immediately knows what just happened
she's great because she's heartbroken
devastated shocked yet she has to
maintain her composure and then she
walks the Lian store and that scene is
so intense where she shot of her face
she's freaking out she's begging without
actually begging you know like it was
powerful Leon's like contemplating it
the whole time it was the perfect way to
have these two characters come together
this is what really United them yeah I
mean I thought he was gonna just let her
in right away but he really let her sit
away from the bonding that develops with
Leon and Natalie Portman's character
Matilda is so natural it's like Leon is
a guy who you learn later on he like he
was pretty much like abandoned he
doesn't even know how to read and it's
kind of a cool exchange like they
eventually develop this relationship
that makes sense like Leon is like I
can't train you you're a little girl you
know he doesn't have the best intellect
she says she's 18 and he kind of like
believes her well yeah he even tells his
boss that she's that she's 18 yeah I
mean the boss didn't buy it Leon's very
sensitive and sincere and you know
because he's a foreigner it's probably
harder for him to pick up on the fact
that people are lying sometimes they're
joking yeah you really sympathize for
his character yeah I love that scene
when Natalie Portman discovers his guns
and you know he learned that he's a
cleaner she wants to be a hitman he's
refusing so she takes the gun and start
shooting at the city it was funny they
have to move you see her street skills
in the very next scene when they were
looking for a new apartment when they're
checking to the apartment and then they
noticed like the violin case yeah and
Leon doesn't know what to say right when
she lies and and covers it up and
you know they get away with it like when
she starts shooting and then the scene
after with him her lying you really
start to see how dark this girl really
him and what she's capable of
she's a grown woman in a little girl's
body right yeah you know like you know
nowadays you get a lot of actresses who
are you know they might be like 12 but
they're trying to act like they're 18
but this is a role were like she's young
and she feels like a kid but there's a
maturity about her and the scene that's
not in the original cut from my
understanding is actually the the scene
on the rooftop with the sniper he's
saying like the first thing you gotta
learn is how to be a sniper
that scene was great because it's cool
same time you're questioning them you're
not sure if you should like this or not
because they're about to just murder
some random person person yeah and then
she shoots and it reveals it's a
paintball that was great
it's a great moment for the audience
it's not just them bonding through the
training like there seems like there's
that one scene where she's like pretty
much playing charades
she's like putting on these costumes and
knacks and he has to guess who it is
and he's so it's funny but it's it's
also when you start to feel that awkward
feeling because she's starting to come
out in sexy outfits and he doesn't know
how to feel about it like I feel a
little I feel weird saying this Leon is
obviously like confused it's like you
get the idea that you might even be
tempted yeah no no because she's like
really coming on it yeah that's my point
I'm like I kind of understand why you
would feel that way you don't know how
to feel about it to you like from an
outsider's perspective it's wrong wrong
wrong yeah but then when you're seeing
into their lives and seeing their
personalities and their chemistry it's
like it makes sense yeah it makes it a
no and I'm glad like there wasn't a
scene where Leon's like I love you yeah
I thought I thought they were gonna kiss
at one point yeah so did I if they did
that then I would been like ok words
were no nevermind the contemplation is
good enough alone I just love seeing
Natalie Portman's like character
evolvement into something even darker as
the
she just starts shutting off from
emotions as things go and like she even
tells the guy at the lobby like he's my
lover he's stuff like she's living in a
different world in that way yeah it kind
of seems like she's redirected all of
her emotions and her strife to Leon and
her feelings towards Leon and of course
the revenge that she wants well from a
psychological point of view it does make
sense because she feels well literally
it was rescued by him and no one's ever
been that kind to her all the training
sequences are great you know I love all
those moments where they're breaking in
with the [ __ ] you know yeah people
and then he anyway breaks the chains off
on the walks and stuff that was a great
montage of stuff it's cool because she's
shoots someone list with another
paintball gun but then the audience
thinks that it's a railgun and again
like this nightmare it's not yeah she's
great in it I love the foreshadowing of
the ring trick with the grenade
basically and how he uses it to kill
that one person you know it's great for
shadowing towards what happens in the
end towards the finale and the whole
finale just kicks into high gear I love
it when Leon's like I need some alone
time I need some space and then Natalie
Portman's like [ __ ] this I'm gonna go
kill these guys I'm sick of this well is
she no he's actually trying to seek her
revenge yeah and she thinks she's being
clever with the pizza delivery stuff but
then Gary Owen shows up cuz he's smart
that's what's cool about this villain is
he's smart like he's a nut job but he's
he's clever though you know that was a
great scene because the first time I saw
it I'm like I can actually see him
really killing her like it's because
he's so believable the way he's
antagonizing her is so scary
what's great it's like when you brought
up she thinks Leon doesn't give a [ __ ]
about any of this but he's really taking
out Gary Oldman's guys actually saves
her from being killed in the bathroom
because your Oldman has to tend to that
now yeah great [ __ ] writing man it's
like it's not about coincidence like it
makes sense yeah and then it's full of
surprises throughout the entire movie
it keeps you guessing and I love the
moment where she's kept hostage by the
cops and it was cool Leon breaks into
the DA's office and then it was right
before that it was still them like Leon
is still trying to act like he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about her yeah he's still
trying to not care but then he saves her
and then they immediately embrace each
other and it's a beautiful moment
because it's like yeah these two
Outsiders loners they really only have
each other at this point you know I'm
not a huge fan of violence but when
there's violence combined with with like
heart I'm definitely into that well it's
because none of the action sequences in
this film like even the finale the
finale is so cool like when all the SWAT
teams and cops are just like I mean I
thought it's a little over the top when
they're really he's like a little cheesy
boat but when everyone starts showing up
but the way they executed the action
scenes was stylish but it was believable
at the same time and the violence is
intense but it's not brutal yeah it's
not it's not um exploitation type of
violence it's justified well every
action scene every violent moment makes
sense for it to be there at that
particular time this is really about the
characters the whole time so when the
action comes in because not a lot of
action but when the action comes in
you're like a hundred times more
invested because you love these
characters right oh yeah there's this
one moment in the finale that was so
funny but cool one of the cop dudes
whatever is like looking over and they
pointed at his head
because Leon's originally it's cool
because Leon's are just shooting people
up from the ceiling our hero gets shot
you know and that's scary when you're
seeing the professional [ __ ] bleed
he's a human being
and there's scenes earlier in the moment
where he's injured in that film see
where he's injured what everyone see
he's gonna do is try to escape or you
know just keep shooting but he does what
no one would have expected he goes out
into the hallway instead and he points
the gun at him and then the guys like do
you see him like yes like you got so
many people
and it is smart because he knew he had
to take him I had to take him hostage
and you see that all these guys are just
brutal [ __ ] murderers because first
they're like we can't do anything cuz he
has him hostage
but the second Leon shuts the door they
just start annihilating they could do
it's unintentional but they're [ __ ]
still murdering him no one was like whoa
stop we shot the guy yeah that was
probably the most brutally gun
yeah no it's a pretty [ __ ] violent
the last scene with Leon and Mathilda
it's powerful because there's a sense of
urgency he's trying to get her to escape
and the plant you know how did we forget
to talk about the plan plan I don't I
forget to talk about the plan you know
what I mean a plant like the plant he is
that he has he's always establishing
that you know it's the one thing he
loves the one thing he really cares for
he ends up loving this little girl and
he gives her the one thing he loves he's
saying goodbye he knows he he knows he's
probably gonna die but he's still gonna
do his best to get back to her we suck
so much fun yeah incredibly tragic is
from from Natalie Portman Matilda's
point of view mean you see her just
totally falling apart she does not want
to be separated from him she knows what
his fate is most likely going to be he
does that classic Hollywood thing where
okay dress up as the cop and get out of
here but Gary Oldman notices him and
that that's so it's like incredibly sad
because when he's walking he sees a
light I don't know if it's like some
symbolism of you know so much behind
that because it's almost as if he's he's
walking towards a new life like he wants
to start over or something yeah and then
he gets shot that's what I mean Gary
Oldman's smart I mean right before you
get shot you see Gary well omens
character coming behind him and and he
does he doesn't know that he's behind
him and the audience is just like no
well he's about to shoot him and he's
like kind of antagonizing Leon without
antagonizing him in front of him he's
treating him like prey yeah like he's
just he could have shot him without
walking towards him but he decided to
walk towards him for a while then shoot
that was his like signature he loved the
silence before the eggs oh I didn't even
think about that cuz it does go silent
and it's just a little bit of like
operatic type of music I Veronica you
just got hotter yeah I mean it was cool
though cuz the four shattering the ring
trick and then he says for Mathilda so
Matilda's getting her vengeance Gary
Oldman's last line is it's funny because
any time a character dies in a film that
we know I'm always interested to see
what their last words were in his last
words were [ __ ] yeah and he doesn't
overdo it he says the line perfect yeah
you know Matilda goes back to school and
she finds a new home she buries the
planet it's cool because she gets full
closure well maybe not but she gets I do
not put it she buries the plant in
symbolism of burying Leon it's cool
because she never actually murdered
anyone she has the skills now she knows
the mentality she knows the world Leon
says to her at one point you know
killing someone changes you and she
didn't have to go through that horrible
change and I love that with the writing
that they didn't even though the she was
going through the training and she
wanted to be an assassin at the end of
it she wasn't some professional you know
killer she was still just a girl yes a
young girl they told one full story that
weren't trying to franchise anything
else they told a complete story they
didn't try to franchise this out there
was a day and age where movies had just
said we're gonna put our all into one
story and not save some for a sequel
they actually just said we're gonna put
it all in one movie and leave it at that
like Natalie Portman at one point
expressed interest in doing a sequel as
an adult but Luke based on thankfully
denied the offer to do that yeah it's a
fantastic film if you haven't seen it
sorry for telling you everything about
it if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects we have a
lot of [ __ ] on here and you can check
out Veronica's channel there's a lot of
music covers and blogging and stuff and
she's actually working on a cover right
now hopefully they'll be up soon that I
think is awesome it's from The Hunger
Games so keep a lookout for that
pressures on baby
great pressure is on